hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one chance the game where
we play as a scientist or a team of
scientists who accidentally created a
pathogen that is going to destroy the
world in six days now the thing about
this game it came back in like 2010 as
far as I remember and it created a OH in
six days every single living cell on
planet Earth will be dead you have one
chance now the thing about this game
like its name says you only have one
chance to beat the game I didn't play it
when it first came out now I haven't
played the since all right let me get my
mouse out of there oh it's pretty music
and that's a pretty thing in the
background and I've got a lovely
animation cycle good for me and a beard
hurry up honey you'll be late for work
thanks penny I'm guessing you're my wife
and I'm guessing you're my daughter
Molly I'm sorry I destroyed the world do
I really have to go to school today
daddy well I don't know the world the
world's gonna end in six days I'm not
entirely sure does it really matter
anymore today's a big day get a move on
okay smooch goodbye honey I'm off to
destroy everything
can't cancer oh okay I get it yesterday
a team of science is led by dr. pilgrim
cured cancer the demon's been working on
a cure for the illness for seven years
before they made a breakthrough in cell
destruction yesterday the cure currently
known as e 48 k15 could also be used to
fight other harmful cells even the
common cold oh boy okay so it they don't
know yet okay so there's a god damn they
don't know they don't even give me a
week it's six days not seven days I
guess it'd be too much like the ring
little girls crawling out TVs hello guy
how are you doing well if it isn't the
[ __ ] Saviour well what's your problem
not like I destroyed the world or Oh No
well done congratulations John this is a
big step
thanks everybody thanks I'm great you're
welcome I ain't gonna turn bad at all
hello
Annie we should go out for drinks to
celebrate John skip work oh no um I
didn't I didn't quite notice the
pixelated boobs there at first but I
can't be distracted I'm a professional
scientist how dare you even think that I
could be distracted from my work if I
could just okay I'm on my way then bye
ladies
oh boy hello you're not gonna talk to me
okay
lab hello hi good work doc you're gonna
be huge thanks Ryan
sorry bro no entry today okay bro you
have a good one I'm gonna go to the lab
cuz apparently everything is gonna be
horrible soon then work okay move okay
in five days every single living cell on
planet Earth will be dead I have one
chance
I wasted a whole day what the hell I
didn't know I was with that guy copping
an attitude not like he knew that the
world was gonna end today Molly how are
you doing
moms in the bath I'll just get get ready
to say hi to her the phone's been
ringing all morning for you must be
important okay I guess I'll just be on
my way then
honey Oh where's where's the phone phone
over here
phone huh
here deadly the cancer cure discovered
earlier this week has been found to be
beyond deadly according to officials be
48k 15 doesn't stop at only killing
cancer cells the drug goes on to kill
every other living cell and not only the
human body but everything else if the
gas based drug was ever used it could go
on to cause catastrophic damage to the
earth my god that's horrible
you'd think they would run trials before
they just started experimenting on
people you know no thanks thing you
think they would experiment before oh no
oh no oh no
oh no oh no this bad
well at least this guy is gonna yell at
me the first thing I've walk-in yeah
course we're flack Jeon
we're fact we're going to get our
funding pal I don't think that's the
worst of our concerns there boss
let's see oh you're not gonna talk to me
huh
you don't want drinks anymore just kind
of jacked you well whatever
I got work to do it's a it's not really
as dangerous as they say it is is it doc
Ryan don't worry I'm gonna be huge
someday don't you worry about a thing
buddy boo oh man no one's talking to me
this is really really awkward let's go
up to the roof there yeah well hey how's
it going there buckaroo oh good
John what are we done I've done the
tests a thousand times it's so much
worse than we thought will you think of
one of those thousand it's going to
change everything now
[Music]
what what I didn't work in four days
every single living cell on the planet
Earth will be dead you have one chance
how do I fix it how do I fix it huh oh
is that just is that my wife you really
have to go in today I I think so does it
really matter anymore I think so
Oh God
why don't I have to go to school today
you didn't want to go two days ago Oh
everything is horrible
Oh God oh no I just noticed how
everything looks like it's painted on a
canvas that's really cool but Oh God oh
no no no no I now know the end is nigh
Thank You mr. president
world leaders all over the earth address
their people yesterday and told them of
the up and coming end of days the cell
destroying virus has already widely
spread and taking its toll on the world
the first signs of the virus in your
area apparently include plant life dying
this would include things like grass and
trees scientists say at the rate of the
spread of information we have nothing Oh
[Music]
oh good broadcasters that's gonna help
Wow no wait are you the guy that jumped
up no you hit here there must be
something we can do
you're right Bruce there must be
something we can do
what's happening here where is everyone
well I don't know get him in here we
need to work no God
Oh God everyone just abandon all hope
did everyone just abandon all hope oh I
gotta work okay I guess Oh God it's LOX
Wayne is locked I need to do work I need
to work Oh God
boss hey boss boss boss don't worry John
I'm not gonna jump
although I don't suppose it matters ah
god this is so sad
go home and be with your family no I
want to work boss
I wanna I need to fix it boss boss boss
you're going home doc no I need to work
Ryan you with me
we're gonna do this leave that's it in
three days every single living cell on
the planet Earth will be dead that seems
rather final you have one chance
honey honey darling holy why aren't they
responding to me 50% dead by morning
scientists have predicted this by
Saturday morning half of the population
of human of the human of the human that
were we're alive on Monday will be dead
as the death toll rises the unmonitored
will numbers teams of scientists all
over the world are still working on a
cure riots are taking place all over the
world and mass looting is in effect
hello John we need you at the lab we
could be on to something but we
understand if you want to be with your
family
wait Oh God have to make the choice
doing work or be with my family that's
such a horrible choice to make oh no I'm
gonna choose the wrong one okay so I
gotta weigh my options if I stay home
with my family I'm counting on the idea
that everyone else in the world is gonna
work on the cure but if I go to work
then I'm gonna abandon my family they
might die before I get the Cure done ah
ah there's no right answer
oh and there's always the hope that
there's the idea that this is gonna be
no cure ha ha I wish I had a walkthrough
I gotta work I guess I guess hello again
boob lady hey glad you could make it
okay why can't I move you know since
this could be our last day on earth I've
been meaning to ask you something oh
really do you maybe want to get it
really really last days on earth I could
create the cure you want to take me out
on a date I chose to be with my family
you think I'm gonna choose to be with
you
get out of here guy I got work to do I'm
gonna save my family ah we gotta work
Ryan Ryan you're my boy we can do this
my boy
oh no oh no oh no oh no I'm a wrong
choice Molly
Oh Molly silly Molly you're coming with
me
oh my family oh she's running on my bank
oh okay a teddy bear coat you need
anything Molly needs any bear
oh my god in there with Molly games
gonna destroy me hello one other person
I didn't get a paper this morning who's
gonna deliver it take Molly this ah ah I
gotta save Molly oh is it oh please at
least she'll be with me I guess work
come on Molly
oh god there's no one else here are they
dead sorry that written in blood oh god
what happened what happened oh what
happened what happened
did someone wreck up the place what
happened Ryan I'm Ollie will he be a
good girl today find another day I get
one stuck in my foot what the hell was
that I saw something move in the
reflection over the paper Molly Moll you
come with me come with me baby we're
gonna go one chance is it too late
[Music]
there's no one left god I just realized
it
Oh God Molly's not doing okay oh this
game is not okay I realize it half is
let's play has just been me going ah I
don't know what else to say it hurts my
heart so badly Oh what do I do
do I take her to the park or do I go to
work and hope that I can find a cure in
time but we're gonna be like the last
people on earth it said I had one chance
Oh No
Oh what do I do if I go to the park
she's like we're just gonna die anyway
right
ah but what would be the point of living
if there's no one left I guess I have to
take like the chance like logically
speaking I would take the chance at
finding a cure I mean I can still be
with her but oh oh what do I do
I gotta take the chances like the path I
was choosing this is what I would do in
this situation I would do everything I
could to try to save him
Molly what the hell she was on my back
[Music]
boy
[Music]
can't do this to me game it's too sad
he's too sad oh come on I don't want to
live I don't care about me
well that's the saddest thing I've ever
seen is she oh my god
that's not is that the only person left
ah I wouldn't have picked me Oh goddamn
oh my god I hurt so badly I didn't want
to save myself I didn't care about
myself that's so horrible
that's not what I wanted to do ah oh man
oh man
if I had a choice like I mean if God if
I chosen the park Lewis where we are
right now I we would have just died
together but God to live as the only
person left that would drive me crazy
you just end up killing yourself anyway
god damn this is so horrible ah there's
no good answer like I found a cure oh my
god what if I had worked instead of like
oh I know what I needed to do all God
and what if I had worked
instead of gone up to the roof because I
didn't work that day the guy when the
guy when the on the day the guy jumped
off the roof if I had actually gone in
and worked that would give me one more
day of work and I would I would it's not
I need to realize it's not my daughter
but like when I play these games I take
it very personally and I think like as
if that was my daughter and if there was
any way that I could save her like
there's nothing that I wouldn't have
done to like try oh my god I'm just this
game's destroy me I need to stop playing
such emotional games because goddamn I
can't handle them okay so anyway
sorry for ruining everyone's day god
this
gotta be a better way like I'll put a
link in the description of the game you
guys can play for yourselves try to find
a better way please tell me there's a
way that actually works unless this game
is just filled with sadness oh maybe it
would have been better just to spend the
whole time with my family because
probably no way to find a cure and it's
a decision of whether you want to try
hopelessly at finding a cure and then be
the only one left on planet earth I
guess in a cosmic way like if I found a
cure that meant life can eventually go
on on planet Earth
even if humans die out a leaf life won't
end because it said every single living
cell would die but this way the cure is
out there I'm guessing that means that
life can go on but home a God to live
with the knowledge being the last one
would be horrible God it would be so
horrible oh man okay it's a weird
question whether you would want to live
after everyone else is dead I don't I
don't think anyone would take the option
they're like being so alone
not just alone in the sense of being
alone but beyond alone and the idea that
no one will ever ever ever be there
again and humanity ends with you that is
the most horrible thing I could possibly
think of oh but either way I hope this
like I hope this brings about at least a
bit of dialogue in the comments like let
me know what you think of this game
because I want to know and I want to
know if there was the right way to go or
if I made the right choices I don't
think I did it doesn't feel like I did
but either way like his these kind of
games that really show that are the
artistic value of what gaming can bring
about it's so simple in its graphical
style and yet it it makes you feel so
long as you get into the game it makes
you feel and goddamn oh God so either
way well like I said before sorry for
ruining your day I hope you enjoyed this
playthrough I hope you can have
lovely day today because this isn't the
situation and this isn't what's
happening right now in life and there's
there's a lot of flaws like this would
never actually happen
maybe but either way just thank you all
so much for watching check out the other
the other happier videos that I've done
in the description below or in the
annotations
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]